so cooking bowl is another famous fan
theory that states that the Clegane
brothers have Sandor and Gregor the
mountain and hound are gonna end up
fighting each other in this epic
showdown to decide the fate of Cersei
Lannister Gregor the mountain is just a
sadist
and he's a rapist and a murderer and
when when they're little kids he shoves
his brother's face into a fire that's
why Hound is all burnt and he's just had
this lifelong hatred of his brother
so house Clegane Bal gonna happen
because both of the brothers seem to be
kind of dead
well the last we saw the Hound he was
gravely wounded and he dies off-screen
so you know he's probably still alive
but in the book there's a theory called
the gravedigger theory but says that
he's actually been seen and he's alive
and well while Brienne of Tarth is
wandering around Westeros she finds this
place called the quiet Isle it's
basically a monastery when she's there
she meets this reputable healer called
the elder brother while she's talking to
him she finds out that the elder brother
found the Hound you know like really
badly wounded and topped him
but the elder brother also says that the
Hound is at rest but Brienne finds the
hounds horse who's actually really
famous for being untamable and no one
can ride him apart from the Hound and
she also sees this really big guy he's
digging a grave and his face is all
covered and he seems to have the same
kind of wound as the Hound had so Ward
speculated is that when the Hound gets
found by the elder brother and he saves
his life he gives up this persona of the
Hound like all the anger and hatred
inside him so the Hound is put to rest
but Sandor Clegane the man is alive and
well and now deeply religious and the
last time we saw Gregor was the eye
thing when he was fighting against
Oberyn Martell in one that fight but
also he got pronged by a poisoned spear
so he was gonna die but then Circe's
weird Meister Qyburn said oh I can save
him but the process might change him a
bit so it's a really deadly poison that
he got stuck with so it's highly likely
that he died but I been managed to keep
him alive through some weird dark arts
so we've seen him like ride under a
sheet and at the end of season 5 when
Circe's walk through King's Landing
a big hulking
member of the Kingsguard just picks her
up and so that's you know that's
probably the mountain so when Cersei got
arrested
she chose a trial by combat and now she
has the reanimated body of the mountain
to fight for her the faith has the newly
pious hound to fight for them
basically for gain Bowl